governor meatball has attacked
it was a sneak attack it wasn't
completely
unexpected i did see the potential for
this i didn't
vocalize it because i didn't want to
manifest
it uh i don't know who
the department of health the governor
cuomo
or somebody in the governor's office
shut
down governor's comedy club
which was doing outside socially
distanced
safe shows in a tent
in a parking lot outside
and it had been open for a while and
many people had performed there
and there were no problems and nobody
had been tested positive for covet 19
but yours truly
criticized the governor of the state of
new york
on the biggest podcast in the world
and then a few days later
a few hours before i was supposed to
perform
in the tent the shows were canceled and
governors got shut down now
i am not alleging that there is a
connection but i cannot
say there isn't a connection do you see
what i'm saying i don't know
i don't know i believe we're now in a
war
i'm in a war with this crime fan can we
be honest
they're a crime family mario cuomo
the grandfather was the governor now
this guy's the governor his brother's on
cnn
they're a crime family that chose to run
the state of new york
instead of a trucking company that's who
they
are and i don't care that chris
uh fredo uh cuomo corleone's wife
is a member of the southampton bathing
corp you can't
wash the garlic out of your dress we
smell you from a million miles away
you can walk on the beach with wasps
wearing white linen
but you smell like a three-day-old
sausage and pepper hero
under the seat of a [ __ ]
i know you try to wash that off but it
seeps out of your pores
and i did you know she's a member of the
very elite
southampton bathing corp one of the
oldest and most prestigious
beach clubs in the world
which means nothing to me
so i walked right you know out out they
you know they they have
obviously a building in a pool and an
inside that you can't get in
but there's a beach there they're out
there they're sitting on the beach
and these wasps used to own the whole
world and now they have this small
patch of dirt in southampton and these
are
you know 800 of the wealthiest families
uh on the planet and
many of them have memberships to this
beach club and they all
drive beater old cars there it would be
seen as grotesque to show up in a lambo
or uh you know uh you know a bugatti
something ostentatious it is very wasp
aesthetic over there and i walked
through it i walked through the beach
part of it
you know there's women wearing like
white bonnets and kids i mean it looked
kind of like a regular
you know beach club you could t you know
the difference was that people were
reading
let's be honest that was the major
difference a couple of people had a few
books and not trashy
romance novels where there's like a guy
whose packs are busting out of his
shirt you know it looks like some
[ __ ]
you know lager you know on the front
cover of the book and
it was in harry potter it wasn't adults
reading harry potter
like a lot of the beaches i go to where
it's an adult
reading tween fiction an adult sitting
there
unashamed reading tween fiction it
wasn't that
i couldn't see what the books were but i
could tell by their covers
they were not that but other than that
other than the fact that you saw people
reading age-appropriate material
it wasn't that obvious that it was uh
so different from the types of people
that would just
normally congregate on a beach in a
well-to-do area i mean there were no
boom boxes i don't want to be racist
here and this is going to seem racist
but you know what i mean
nobody was playing loud music there were
no potato
chips nobody had a bag of lay's
potato chips nobody was sitting
around uh crunching
cheese doodles it was people that were
reading
quietly talking quietly
going in in the water of course there's
no phones allowed no instagram
no tick-tocking no you know there are
strict rules and
christina cuomo
chris uh fredo cuomo
corleone didn't have corona never forget
liar uh his wife christina grissholm
is a member of the southampton bathing
court
do i know can i be certain that she was
not
told that i committed the uh social sin
of walking through the beach club that i
am not a member of
i don't know can i can i be sure can i
be certain that that did not
happen is this a war for the future of
the hamptons
is this the cycles of new money
replacing old
am i locked in the same war that
vanderbilt and carnegie and rockefeller
were in
i could be but i'm ready for it
i'm ready for it i'm here fighting for
your rights
first of all it is your right to die no
one's told you that it's your right to
die it's your right
to die you have a right to die okay
it is not your right to kill other
people but if
if other people all take a risk and kill
each other
you're not killing them do you see what
i mean
like if everybody decides for example
like you know we always talk about drunk
drivers what if everyone in the car is
drunk
do you know how many times i've been in
a car and everyone is drunk
and every time we'd get into an accident
almost people would laugh
nobody in the car deserved to survive
nobody
there was no innocent person in the car
there was no like
good person that had just accidentally
ended up in a car with three other
drunks on a wednesday night in long
island
leaving a bar called lisa's lounge
everybody already had blood
on their hands you see so if everybody
wants to get together and
assess the risk and go out and enjoy
some [ __ ] entertainment
which is i think their god-given right
or
state given they should be able to do
that without the fear
of reprisal from this vindictive
petty gangster who's running new york
state
and this is the play until trump um
is loses and you could hate trump you
could want trump to lose i think it
would be very
healthy for the country to have a reset
right about now but
let's just be honest if you work in the
restaurant business or if you work in
entertainment
be prepared for a rocky couple of months
because
especially if you're in a blue state a
lot of these governors
um they're not going to allow
the phases to reopen in a way that makes
people feel hopeful about the future i
think the plan is
to kind of reopen
uh gradually slowly and
i don't think a hell of a lot of
reopening is going to happen before
november
i just don't believe that and listen
that's a strategy
and it's you know because a lot of these
states don't want to get clobbered again
there's many reasons
but let's not for a minute pretend
let's not for a second pretend that
there isn't a benefit to
keeping the economy stalled
and keeping people a little terrorized
they just want you a little
nervous out there they want you
a little apprehensive out there a little
fearful they want you to know
that society is fragile
and that that is part of
a strategy to force political change in
the country
you may agree with it you may think it's
smart you may
i think it's necessary you might think
it's long overdue
but let's be very honest about what it
is it's not
i think if biden and kamala win the tone
of the coverage is going to change
trump did bungle this i think we can all
agree if we're honest
that trump didn't do a great job i don't
know how well
other presidents would have done and now
we'll never know
i mean we might know if we get a new one
in a few months
but at the end of the day the media
wants
this guy out and they're using every
opportunity
to you know act as a
partisan political
machine that's what they're doing if you
can't see that you
yourself have left the planet which is
okay
that's fine but just know that just you
can see that
and it's not all undeserved that's the
other thing trump
is not above reproach he doesn't he
deserves
a lot of criticism he's the last person
you'd want in any type of crisis
you know he like cuomo is petty he's
vindictive
you know you know i don't know what
cuomo did i haven't really been
following this nursing home scandal
i just know that my mother is in a
nursing home and has not died of covet
and everyone in my family has been
terribly disappointed you know we call
every day and we're like
what what is going on has everyone died
but her
has literally every person died of covet
in the nursing home system but her
this [ __ ] is sucking up tax dollars
like you have no idea
i mean shoot her in the head and just
say it's kophen
who cares they're not gonna care the
people who run this state
are [ __ ] criminals they're gangsters
just smother her with a pillow for
christ
but i don't know what what he's been
doing i think he's just been putting
you know he's just let a brush fire of
covid
run through the nursing home system in
new york state
okay while
he's not canceling comedy shows
held in parking lots he spends his time
shipping sick covert patients to nursing
homes
starting a brush fire of disease
this is a guy who claims how well new
york handled covid
he fails to mention that all of the
outbreaks of kovid
from around the country originate and
emanate from
new york not shutting down immediately
and letting people leave now i'm not
saying that new york
should have shut down or it shouldn't
have shut down but let's look at the
causation of a lot of the
the coveted outbreaks came they can be
directly traced to new yorkers
so before we throw ourselves a victory
party
and before somebody pops out of the cake
and before mama starts rolling the
eggplant rollatini
and before we bring out the chafing
dishes and before we get the [ __ ]
peniela vodka and the chicken frances
and the cannolis out let's understand
that you and your state infected the
entire country yes or yes
those are just facts andrew andy
meatball they're just facts
and you could be a you can revise
history you could do whatever makes you
comfortable
you can get out and uh you know do this
dance do you desperately want to be
president
we've never had an italian president
and we never will we will have a
transgender
member of antifa before we
have uh somebody who smells like garlic
sitting in that oval office okay
criminal
understand that criminal
there's nothing really better than anti
uh
italian racism and because
it is allowed that's just simply why
it's so good
it's it's sanctioned it's allowed
uh nobody uh it will stop you from doing
it in fact
there's only an upside to you engaging
in racism against irish people
or italians which is why i do it so
frequently and because i know
a lot of irish people and italian people
so it's kind of
it's fun to poke fun at them but i mean
if the governor let's
say let's just say for an example the
governor was a black lesbian
let's do the show again ready ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the tim dillon show
the shows got cancelled real
disappointing anyway
heading back to l.a pretty soon really
excited about
you see the difference you see the diff
and that's
unfortunate that is unfortunate
because i do believe that everybody
deserves a good lashing specifically
when they are targeting uh just a clown
just a happy clown coming to dance his
clown dance
for the people in long island the simple
people in long island
who just want to laugh
they just want to laugh and eat bacon
egg and cheese sandwiches and
occasionally do a little heroin
that's all they want to do they want to
live in houses they inherited
and complain about the tax burden